this is the gateway to a key City that
Russian forces captured in the first
weeks of the war but these are Ukrainian
troops
they're part of a lightning advance
retaking swathes of territory across the
kharkiv region punching through Russia's
defenses driving its troops back
in order to achieve the stated goals of
the special military operation to
liberate donbass a decision was made to
regroup the Russian troops stationed to
balaclia and Islam regions to build up
our efforts in the direction of Donetsk
regrouping sounds more like retreating
to reinforce Russia's positions in The
crucial donbass region
the sudden Russian order came as
Ukrainian troops celebrated the
recapturing of the small city of
balaclia the national flag flying high
once more
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclia the first major city in our
offensive I'm sure that it will not be
our last
Russia's worst nightmare appears to be
unfolding in eastern Ukraine it could be
their gravest setback since the failure
to capture Kiev back in March these
pictures were taken from the city of
kupiansk recapturing this place would
deal a significant blow to Russia as
it's been an important Supply route to
support Russian forces in donbath
Russia's decision to pull back some
forces from Eastern positions is
extraordinary but Ukraine is also wading
counter-attacks from the south the
simultaneous operations backed by
Western weapons marked the biggest
Ukrainian offensive of the war and could
be a key turning point if the gains are
sustained
[Music]
for those who've spent months under
Russian occupation the relief is all too
clear to see
they've waited a long time for this
debraham Sky News in eastern Ukraine